[Music]
there are arguably two types of
intelligence
[Music]
fluid intelligence is your ability to
reason quickly and independently of your
past experiences
it relies on the ability to hold
attention and benefits from a strong
working memory while it can be trained
fluid intelligence is mainly determined
by your genes
crystallized intelligence is your
ability to apply knowledge from prior
learning that was stored in your
long-term memory
it increases with experience and is
hence mostly formed by the environment
to solve complex problems both types of
intelligence need to work together
to illustrate how fluid and crystallized
intelligence work let us tell you the
story of arthur a fine young man who
wants to save a young princess that was
captured by an evil witch
the witch promised to release the
princess only if arthur brings her a
precious jewel from a secret tomb
arthur agrees begins his quest and comes
across a deep dark forest that he must
cross
he navigates through the wilderness with
a compass and a map using the
intelligence he crystallized when he
spent lots of time studying maps as a
boy
at the end of the forest arthur
discovers the entrance to the tomb and
sees the prized jewel already sparkling
in the distance
as he enters the tomb he steps on a
pressure plate his crystallized
intelligence tells him that this is a
mechanical trap something he learned
about earlier in life he stands still
and thinks of a solution
since he has never been in the situation
before he cannot draw on past experience
thankfully his fluid intelligence takes
over and allows him to make a new plan
on the fly
drop the bag it puts pressure on the
plate and you can grab the jewel
crystallized intelligence takes note for
future reference
arthur then gave the jewel to the witch
freed the princess and brought her
safely back home
suppose arthur was an average child and
we were able to plot the development of
his intelligence over 90 years
his fluid intelligence would increase
sharply until his early 20s and then
peak and decline his crystallized
intelligence would peak later and slowly
decline at a higher age
the psychologist raymond cattle coined
the terms fluid and crystallized
intelligence in 1963.
[Music]
what are your thoughts can you think of
a time when you use your fluid and when
you use your crystallized intelligence
share your thoughts in the comments
below
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do
to learn how it works and download this
video without ads or background music
check out our website or read the
description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts
you